I read the book what they don't teach
you at Harvard University but out of all
the books if I was going to recommend to
you if you're wanting to get into
business I would recommend this one it
goes through sales negotiations
management it's just a brilliant staple
you know when you go for a nice meal and
you have like a roast dinner that's this
this is like a staple meal there's
nothing in here that I read that was
groundbreaking or like oh it's
completely changed the way I view life
and business but it was just really
refreshing if you're starting out
business this is going to really really
help you with the fundamentals of
business I enjoyed this